and finally new rule for all the
progressives and academics who refer to
Israel as an outpost of Western
Civilization like it's a bad thing
please note Western Civilization is what
gave the world pretty much every goddamn
liberal precept that Liberals are
supposed to
adore individual liberty scientific
inquiry rule of law religious freedom
women's rights human rights democracy
trial by jury freedom of speech please
somebody stop us before we Enlighten
again and since one can find all these
Concepts in today's Israel and virtually
nowhere else in the Middle East if
anything the world would be a better
place if it had more israels of course
this message falls on deaf ears to the
current crop who reduce everything to
being only victims or victimizers so
Israel is lumped in as the toxic fruit
of the victimizing West the irony being
that all marginalized people live better
today because of Western ideals not in
spite of
them Martin Luther King used Henry David
Thor's essay Civil Disobedience to help
shape the Civil Rights Movement the un's
universal Declaration of Human Rights
owes its core to rouso and vol
kenes never showed up for a sexual
harassment
seminar but without him there's no
democracy the cop who murdered George
Floyd got 21 years for violating his
fourth amendment rights an idea we got
directly from John Lock who no one in
college would ever study anymore because
he's so old and so white and so
dead
so Western yes that's how simple the
woke are it's never about ideas if it
was would they be cheering on Hamas for
their
Liberation Liberation to do what more
freely Pride over a country where there
are no laws against sexual harassment
spousal rape domestic violence
homophobia honor killings or child
marriage this is who liberals think you
should stand with women there should be
so lucky as to get colonized by anybody
else and for the record the Jews didn't
colonize Israel or anywhere ever except
maybe boa
Ron G Gaza wasn't seized by Israel like
India or Kenya was by the British Empire
and the partitioning of the region
wasn't decided by Jews but by a vote of
the United Nations in 1947 with with
everyone from Russia to Haiti voting for
it but apparently they don't teach this
at drag queen Story Hour
anymore
now it is true that for too long we
didn't study enough Asian or African or
Latin American history but part of the
reason for that is frankly there's not
as much to study colleges replaced
courses in Western Civ
boo I roll dead white men am I
right they replace that with World
Civilization classes which is fine in
theory but what it meant in practice is
you read queer poetry of the African
diaspora instead of Shakespeare and I'm
sure there's value in both but as usual
America only ever
overcorrects and so we're at this place
now where the words Western Civ became
kind of a Shand for white people ruined
everything but
but they didn't ruin everything no they
didn't live up to their own ideals for
far too long and committed atrocities
but people back then were all
atrocious not just the white ones
depending on who had the power but it
was the Western Enlightenment that gave
rise to the notion that the law of the
Jungle should be curbed Henry David
thorough John Stewart Mill Ralph Waldo
Emerson Johan rouso three named
dudes it was all about three named
dudes three na like that were the OG
social justice Warriors the ideas that
came through Athens Rome London Paris
and yes Philadelphia are what make life
good for most people in free societies
today that the individuals have value
and even the powers that be must submit
to the rule of law that punishment
should not be cruel and unusual that the
accused get PE people get a trial that
there is such a thing as a war crime why
is it that every other culture gets a
pass but the West is exclusively the sum
of the worst things it's ever done you
think only white people colonized
historians estimate that the very
non-western Mr genas
Khan killed 40 million people and that
was in the 13th
century he single-handedly may have
reduced the world's population by
11% on the other
hand he kind of made up for it because
he was such a prolific colonizer of
vaginas that today an estimated 16
million people are his direct
descendants so stop saying Western
Civilization like it's a contradiction
in terms it's not you're thinking of
moderate
Republican